hey what's up everyone it's date sales
I'm Kate Quigley I'm here Brendon is
recording me right now on my right I've
got Breton Biddle Combe hilarious
comedian and also the social media guy
for all things comedy and the Comedy
Store and button aren't you like the
youngest paid regular in Comedy Store
history no not the youngest I think
that's Kevin Hicks oh really
yeah he was like 17 or 19 really do you
know how old were you when you got
passed I was 25 oh okay young face I
know I thought you were like 21 no you
know the way my weeks been going it
wouldn't be surprised that happens this
weekend think you know it's all going
downhill we'll talk about it only
Thursday my BFF hilarious comedian
actress everything Jen started adding
adjunct professor to that yeah I got a
class this weekend University of Florida
yeah talk about that you went you were
like a college professor by the way you
must have been like the hottest college
professor like every student must have
been like well that football team did
hit on me like a man they say all of
them just a few of them enough to eat
even like I'll take all of your phone
numbers on the sign-in sheet like you to
pass it down no way yeah did you hand
out my number to all the players no okay
what kind of friend are you
no how was it it was a lot of fun what
did you teach I taught sports media but
it was really cool because I sat in the
back of the class and I dressed like a
kid and I put like a baseball hat on and
then I started talking [ __ ] to the
professor in the middle of the class
like like five minutes in because they
said that the speaker had canceled for
the day and so I was like so wait do you
like wanna speaker and I'm dressed like
a kid and I look like a kid and I'm
their size you know what I mean like
actually a lot of them were bigger than
me yeah it was depress
especially the football players well the
greatest part about that is what I sat
down in the class before the class
actually started one of them looked over
at me and of course his name was
Chauncey
and he looks over at me and he goes hey
ain't you that girl that sits back there
with the white Nike hat on and I was
like yes so when it got in her when I
got introduced by the way and like ran
down the aisle like I was like Oh in
WrestleMania you know yeah everyone was
losing their mind because they thought I
was just some kid talking [ __ ] to the
professor terrifying this was at Florida
State
no I was at Florida oh sorry that's a
rival school oh it was did they still
know who you were though oh yeah oh
that's so funny did everybody everybody
must have wanted like pictures and stuff
afterwards
hmm nice I was like you guys better put
every filter imaginable dude I'm
surprised you don't when people ask me
for photos I'm like can I just see that
real quick before you post it and then
if it's bad I just delete it off their
phone accidentally deleted it great
fronting you're the man
so we've got Breton in today okay like I
have tie with some really a grow music
you started this I know this is I'm a
little angry today's episode of date
veils is brought to you by anger that's
pretty much what's happened to you by
PMS let's keep it real okay I'm also PMS
it so it's great I text yet on the way
here I'm like I'm really pissed off at
men and I'm PMSing so what happened kick
how you feign concern what happens Kate
I don't even know where to start I think
we had to backtrack to last week's
episode okay yeah so last week on date
fails I had my friends carry Ariel and
krysta and basically we talked about
doing a 30-day challenge all three of us
fought four of us because we're all just
not doing well with men
we all have keep dating [ __ ] and
keep falling for [ __ ] and so we
decided that we need to learn to love
ourselves and take a break from guys and
so we all decided we were gonna go 30
days without having sex no sex and also
we were gonna do other things like daily
what do you call it meditate
and you know we're gonna send each other
like inspirational quotes really dumb
[ __ ] that girls do okay this is some
real Spice Girls Josh exactly 40 days
and 40 nights yeah yeah yeah so so that
was the plan and they ruined his career
not having sex no we don't that's the
end of that question goodbye yeah well
so we all left here and I was like so
inspired and all these people by the way
like listeners were like sending me
messages in fact one guy even sent me
PayPal money and he said hey this is so
you have something else to do this month
besides to have sex use this money and
have some fun I'm really bored and I
need something to do you know he sent 15
dollars so I don't know how much fun he
was expecting me to have with it but I
was so grateful he knows he's playing at
the dollar store
really good time for me we could we
could have an hour of fun at the dollar
store just blocked his number so I was
super excited yeah I was really proud
and excited every time my phone went off
I wasn't like worried if it was drama
and it felt good have you ever blocked a
girl's number
no oh well I feel like he's pretty on
the level he might not have you ever had
any dramatic relationships that were
like extremely tumultuous not really no
and I've been in a very good
relationship for over two years now met
her on tinder did you really know oh my
god someone sent me this story today
they're like you have to talk about this
this girl and guy met on tinder she went
to his place she got drunk
apparently they started fighting and he
locked her on the balcony and wouldn't
let her back in the apartment so she
tried to climb down
she fell and she died and someone said
it to me and was like well at least no
matter how bad your love life is it
can't be going this bad I was like no
I'll probably end up jumping off a
balcony let's be realistic
it's not dating anyone that was on the
14 story of anything
no one I would date would have a balcony
she's right you can't stack benches on
top of each other
so okay so Bretton you mayor gone tinder
yeah no way what does she do
she works at Hulu cool a real job
oh yeah what a real person I know what
was your first date we went and saw the
Dark Knight and need dome at our clay
time sitting in the dark and not
speaking on another game the second date
like two nights later okay you follow up
that fast oh yeah wait the second date
you went to a baseball game how long in
between the first and the second day two
days Kate he's already spent more money
on this girl in two dates then people
have spent on you in the last two thank
you Jen talked for like a month before
we met up yeah how interesting so cuz
usually if guys hit me up on those
dating apps and they don't ask me out
within the first like four or five
back-and-forth text it has no chill no
chill I this is what I do I write them
and I go like this happened yesterday I
matcha the guy on rheya yesterday
cop-out by the way he had a photo of him
in a Clippers outfit playing basketball
so I thought he was I did some research
and tonight he was equipped for like 10
days and now he plays in the d-league or
whatever in the Development League
yes he plays in the D we're just still
find it was really high he's 610 no I'm
not sure I think that's too big of a
height gap her ex before me Wes was six
five or six three and how tall is she
she's my height like we're the same
height well that's okay I think I think
sick cuz I've dated a lot of six fours
and I think that's okay but 610 that's
like I think if we were having sex I
couldn't even reach his face I think
he'd be okay with okay so you met your
girl on tinder first date movie did you
do anything else that night of the movie
or just the movie just the movie Wow huh
yeah see it's possible to go on a date
with person didn't have sex with that's
not what I meant you know I don't
sex on the first date ever only once and
it wasn't a date
right oh forget that we're working in a
non visual medium right now people can't
just see me staring at you and disbelief
actually people can so continue yeah
okay
so back to the 30-day challenge I am
fascinated by your tinder story that
we're gonna get back to this and because
I might start dating on tinder now you
just gave me hope I'm onsen grace I'm on
tinder
last night I tendered like 50 people in
San Diego I like to have options on the
road you know I mean Jim people can't
see you okay anyway back to this soap so
I blocked his number let's call that guy
[ __ ] I blocked it I do all the time
I blocked his number and I felt great
about it and then and then I started
meditating and that's pretty going
pretty well I've got a mantra off the
Internet what is it like you can't tell
it you're not allowed to tell your
mantra it's probably a lyric to a Spice
Girls song or something super dog no
it's like it's not even a word it's just
a sound it's just a sound you make you
know what I mean like I own YouTube so
this is a cat going yeah yeah I have a
mantra and I'm meditating and and things
are good so I leave the podcast that's
day one and I had a booty call scheduled
for that night okay
he already canceled that yeah obviously
yeah and you know this booty call let's
call him I don't know what to name these
guys let's just call him um Brock okay
so I'm supposed to have actually sounds
realistic okay I was supposed to hang
out with Brock Brock and I have only
hooked up once but the sex was like
really really really good but I knew I
didn't want to date him so I never saw
him again but then I decided I might as
well use him as a booty call so I had
set him up for that night and then I
when I decided on the 30-day challenge I
text him and I said hey it's a long
story but I can't [ __ ] you tonight so um
what to hang some other time and he was
like
okay I hope everything's okay and I was
like yeah everything's fine I'm just
working on myself yeah I was like I'm
just taking a break from sex right now
and he wrote back herpes sucks and then
though like three hours later he texts
me which came as a complete surprise and
he said you know we don't have to have
sex we can just hang out I actually like
hanging out with you like as a friend if
you want to do that and I was like so
shocked so I was like okay why not we
should do that so we got together after
my show that night we had two drinks and
we made out and I wanted to fog him
really bad but I didn't I left the bar
and I went home alone thank you and I
was really proud of myself as a slow
clap thank you well I was really proud
of myself because at that point I had
already gone one week without sex by
accident but still so that was like
eight days so I loved it you can't
retroactively your days like it's not
like a DL where you're like it's a
retroactive DL like you can't no you
can't do that really
no I the 30-day challenge starts on the
day you issue the 30 day challenge us
saying to be fair to me technically
we're on day two three okay but
technically I'm just saying it had
already been a week and I was really
horny and I still said no so I just feel
like I should get a little extra all
right what's the next one all right so
that was day one no I'm sorry that was
day that was day two that was Friday
we should taped on Thursday that was
Friday okay that was day two minutes a
day - okay all right I need that because
I don't remember what happened that's my
cheat sheet okay so day Oh
day three oh by the way one thing I
didn't throw in is parlours I didn't
[ __ ] him as I purposely didn't shave so
that I wouldn't [ __ ] him that works I
his help it really does work yeah I was
like okay I can't Brenda would you care
if you went to go hook up with a girl
and she hadn't shaved no not really
because like by the way when girls who
are like like have laser
like they maintain stuff really well
don't you like a straight hair yeah
stubble but for me that's enough to be
like no one's going in there that's it
oh by the way he's like why did I sit
into this chair things that are growing
hair in your refrigerator that have more
hair on them my legs
almost every other day okay so moving on
the next night I had a gig so I had to
go to Santa Barbara so there was no
thought old people there there's
something I'm forgetting oh my god I'm
forgetting the most important part of
the story the day of the challenge the
day we taped the podcast this is a big
important thing I went out that night
and I ran into a friend now this is a
guy I've been friends with for like
three years and we used to live in the
same building and we have always had
like crazy sexual attention he's one of
those friends that I was like uh if I
was gonna bang one of my friends it
would totally be this guy but he always
had a girlfriend from the first time I
met him so crazy girlfriend yes and but
this guy and I we always had this flirty
thing and it's always been a thing where
he's like if I didn't have a girlfriend
we'd be dating and I'm like I know
totally
but we never hooked up so I run into him
the night of the podcast and he tells me
him and his girlfriend broke up but they
had only broken up like two weeks before
so I was like oh yeah well first of all
I just started this 30-day challenge so
that's good and secondly you just broke
up with this girl so you should probably
take a minute and deal with this you
know and we can maybe hang out and he's
like well let's just hang tonight and go
get drinks so we did we hung out that
night and we went and had drinks this is
the night of the 30 day challenge we
went and had drinks and I got kind of
drunk and I made out with this guy at
the bar how do you forget what happened
on night one
I cancelled the booty call and then I
ran into this guy day one I didn't plan
on it it just happened and I definitely
didn't plan on making out that's the
universe having a sense of humor it's
like by the way you're gonna give you
the best possible dick you could
possibly have tonight and you have to
say no to it yeah Jen knows this guy
he's like Brad Pitt hot yeah he's so hot
and like and he's actually cool so it's
the worst possible person to run into
who's like I'm suddenly singing uh okay
I felt for you that night I usually
don't I'm usually like you you brought
this on yourself it's always like don't
you dare hook up with him and I text her
and I go hey so-and-so broke up with his
girlfriend and he's hitting on me and
she's like you have my permission to
[ __ ] in the morning so that happened day
one I forgot about the making out day
two I hung out with the booty call guy
but we did not have sex so that's where
we're at and I have to go on with this
to say that all day on day two hot guy
we'll call him Brad Pitt Brad Pitt is
texting blowing you up blowing me up
like texting me every two hours all day
we got to hang out again I dig you I'm
finally single let's do this that it oh
whatever
so that night I you know I hung out with
the other guy I kind of blew off Brad
Pitt cuz I knew I would probably bang
him if I hung out with him so I did not
hang out with him then day three I had
to go to Santa Barbara for a gig thank
God so I was away so there was no
possibility of anything happening day
three so fast forward today for day four
is Sunday so Sunday is football day I'm
hanging out with my friends watching
football I go to the pool I have a
couple drinks oh God
Brad Pitt is still texting me all day I
love that we're calling him Brad Pitt
yeah still texting me all day so Sunday
night he's like hey let's meet up
what's hangout come come meet up with me
and my friend at this bar and I do I go
meet up with him and his friend and we
just hang out for a couple hours and
then afterwards she's like you want to
get out of here I live right up the
street and I'm like I'll go home with
you but no
we can't have sex I'm on a 30-day
challenge and also you just broke up
with your girl and I was like and I
actually like you I've known you for a
while so if we [ __ ] it's gonna be like
you know it's gonna mean something it's
not just gonna be like a one-off to me
so he's like I didn't know sex we'll
just hang out you know so we go back to
that [ __ ]
well for sure you wanted to [ __ ] right I
mean guys want to [ __ ] but he was he's
really a nice guy yeah he's not a dick
so I really believe that he does like me
but you know he just broke up with a
girl you've been with for years so he
can't be ready right you never just
occurred to me though what Aaron's the
real Brad Pitt just broke up with the
perfect name for him duh I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna comment on that honey kids
does he have oh so I go back to Brad's
place and lots of heavy padding no sex
did not [ __ ] him and can I just say if
ever a girl deserved some kind trophy
metal because leaving that place without
[ __ ] this guy is maybe the hardest
thing I've done I mean I have you ever
had such insane chemistry with someone
you just know the sex is gonna be like
[ __ ] yeah so you were just like but
I didn't do it I walked away thank you
that was ID and I left and I texted
everyone I know and I said oh my god not
only did I block [ __ ] phone number
this week haven't talked to him been
meditating every day also I made out
with Brad Pitt didn't [ __ ] him I am like
killing it the 30 day challenge okay
that's safe for so day five I was super
busy I had a gig that night he was also
texting me again every hour or two all
day and wanted to hang that night and I
didn't I blew him off again I was again
very proud plus you an early call time
the next day that's beside the point
check let's go
I couldn't even convince you to come to
the airport to pick me up when I
realized that my flight was on the next
day so it's totally irrelevant but
whatever how many times have I driven to
the bat listen how many times have I
driven all the way to the valley to [ __ ]
[ __ ] when I have like a 6:00 a.m.
call time because when you don't come
get me at the airport yeah I know well
you don't go down on me if you had
offered Kate you give me a ride from LAX
and I will promise you ten orgasms I
would have picked you up pass all right
so weird that my lesbianism draws a line
there I'm like a drug makeout session
maybe but like actually going for like
fish sandwich no thank you yeah no I I
don't blame you it's gross I really did
have an early call time I get up at like
7:00 a.m. so I went home okay so now
we're on day six so day six day thirteen
as Kate likes I wake up day six I'm at
work shooting again Brad is texting me
all day and hears it sucks now I'm
starting to kind of like him cuz that's
what happens to girls like guys don't
get that and he's saying things to me
like I really like you I think we'd be
really great we should actually date I
would totally date you I'm not getting
by the way the whole time
I'm like dude you're probably gonna get
back together with your girl nobody
breaks up after this long and doesn't at
least get back together once so you need
to slow your roll and he's like no no
we're not gonna get back together we're
not gonna get back together right so I'm
like all right he's texting me all day
day six I'm like maybe you know we can
hang again let me think about it
then he then he text me a couple hours
later and he says hey listen I gotta
tell you cuz I don't want you to find
out some other way that Sheila his ex is
coming into town today to pick up her
stuff and she really wants to talk
brenton just cringed about getting back
together but I don't want to I just want
you to know that she's gonna be here and
so you know I don't want you to see it
on facebook or something and freak out
because when I go to pick up my [ __ ] at
my ex's house I'm like going to pick out
my shirt yeah I mean and I really I know
and so I wrote him back and was like
listen I'm not surprised I kind of saw
this coming in my mind I'm like they're
totally getting back together
obviously he's warning me because he
doesn't want look like an [ __ ] so I'm
like hey totally saw this coming no big
deal if you guys get back together you
and I are cool nothing really happened
we just kind of made out and you know
that's fine thanks for being honest so I
left it there and then he was like well
can we still just like talk and stuff
and I was like well I think we should
chill for a while until you you know
this is really over for you just not and
he was like okay
and then like an hour later he texts me
like actually no I'm not doing that and
then he kept texting me and texting me
and texting me and texting me and and I
was trying to be strong but then to be
honest with you the minute I found out
his girl was coming back into town and
the minute I realized what a horrible
idea it would be to [ __ ] him it just
made me want to [ __ ] like 10 times
more I mean you know when you shouldn't
[ __ ] someone how much more you want to
do it no Kate I don't really 10 retinas
are you like that no we're well-adjusted
Kate that's why all right fine
well sorry 19 year-old all right well I
I said no I'm not hanging out with you
I'm a I made other plans
here are my plans for the night this is
what's happening I'm going out with my
friends so you have a good night and
that was that and then because I am me
and I can't ever stick to anything when
I went to meet my friends at the bar
I text him and I was like you know what
Jen stop it it was like listen you and I
were already friends before we can still
be friends if you want to come hang out
with me and my friend at the bar you can
I won't touch you because we're not
gonna [ __ ] but like you can come hang
out and mm-hm and then what happened is
he did but all my friends flake so I
ended up just being the two of us and
then one thing led to another and we got
a little drunk and then we went back to
his place and then I was like well I'm
definitely not [ __ ] you but I'll come
up and then and then we bought and then
I [ __ ] him
so the point of the story is I broke the
30-day challenge on day six but it was
kind of did 13 thanks Jen that makes me
feel better I'm Dave I broke it we
hooked up but now you're in a really
weird place now I'm in a weird place so
I left his place that night I didn't
stay and he was like do you want to stay
and I'm like no I really don't I'm like
at his place and I'm looking around and
like his exes stuff is still there it's
too weird that's the best clue that
something's wrong right is when the exes
stuff is still there like when you broke
up with girls like what did you do with
their stuff like their personal life yes
brenton well I've only had one situation
where that's happened one breakup yeah
where you were like living together yeah
okay how long did it take her to get her
stuff out it was a few months what yeah
Wow now is she like leave stuff behind
to like drag it out or like what I don't
know just took her a while to get it and
I think she was trying to get situated
and I wasn't the kind of guy that was
like hey you have to get this now or I'm
gonna put it all out sure yeah well but
let me ask you like it's on the front
porch come by and get it whenever you
feel like it
Jen would I don't I don't have that in
me it's a quota girl at the University
of Florida the other day she goes Jen is
Savage AAF you are Jen is Jen is like
like cuz I haven't finished the story
with Brad Pitt yet but Jen's Jen is
telling me to send like these mean - Jen
is so much meaner than me but like in a
great way like she treats guys the way
they should they deserve to be treated
when they treat her a certain way I am
like a pushover and I'm wade through
nice butt so let me ask you this when
you're a girl that you lived with how
long were you guys together uh almost a
year but we had only been living
together for three months and when you
broke up did you get back together at
all no you so you ended it she left but
then she was slowly getting her stuff I
broke up with him I don't want to I
don't want to name names no I meant like
who broke up with no she broke up with
me oh she did yeah and you still let her
leave her stuff there for three months
God you are a nice guy yeah Wow
are your parents still together oh yeah
I knew it my immigrant parents all right
well so so he is like do you want to
stay over and I am by the way
this is kind of a sign though because he
was like do you want to stay over like
no you left out the most important part
of this story I didn't so kate tells me
well here's the thing
we had sex on the couch you wouldn't
take me in his room yeah I thought it
was really weird he didn't try to take
me in the bedroom but then when he
offered to let her sleep over he was
like we could just sleep out here okay
he was like we could sleep here and then
I could tell he looked like I looked at
him weird and then he was like oh I mean
or you know and in the bedroom but I
could tell that he felt he must still in
his mind feel like he's cheating like he
can't take another yeah in there or he's
got pictures of her everywhere right for
sure there's like [ __ ] so I was like no
you know I don't really like to stay
over which is true I don't stay over
unless I'm like really super into
someone and I knew in my heart plus if
he cuddles are it's over yeah well I
knew I'm like if I sleep here I will
wake up with feelings period no matter
what I can't help it when I leave
burning so I already it was like [ __ ] I
shouldn't have [ __ ] him I mean I knew
the minute it was done and I got dressed
I got out of there pretty quick and then
I got home what's your Excuse when you
leave right after in this case I was
just like I'm really tired which I was
there's a bed right there so what's your
excuse for leaving I told him I don't
sleep over unless I'm like seriously
dating someone I just said that really
yeah I said I don't sleep over and he
was like will you'll sleep over next
time and I was like probably not I mean
I'm honest because that's how I catch
really strong feeling you're like look
you don't live in Reseda
so this yeah
drive home for me in a way cheaper
uber so do you understand how happy I
was for a minute can I just say like and
the reason I'm so disappointed because I
was so excited to be into a guy who's
super hot actually cool that I have
amazing chemistry with who isn't an
[ __ ] who actually was being nice to
me like that's never happened to me ever
in my life that I've been like really
into someone and sexually attracted to
them and they're nice never happened
before
yeah but what part of your brain was
like his ex-girlfriend is coming into
town this is the perfect night so no no
no I knew it was a bad idea okay I knew
it was a bad idea
and and but alcohol man don't drink you
know alcohol [ __ ] with like I never
would have [ __ ] him sober and that's
so I go home okay I take an uber i leave
and by the way can I say what's this
with your uber on the way home I feel
like that would be a really funny
periscope from now on whenever you leave
someplace like in the walk of shame you
just talk to them like a free therapy
session and see how much you can get
them to interact with you no but can I
say one other thing like can I record an
episode of my podcast right now yeah I
thought about that why is it like the
minute a guy [ __ ] you though their
behavior changes immediately because the
other night when I was at his place and
we didn't [ __ ] I called an uber and he
walked me down to the uber and he kissed
me goodbye at the over and this time
after we [ __ ] I called an uber and
he's like to remember how to get out
guys after you [ __ ] up it's like up to
Walker the guy my kid when he said that
Oh uh-oh cuz that would have been a good
excuse I don't care I mean come on okay
but anyone flip-flops and walk me down
yeah yeah
so I leave I go home already regret it I
go to sleep I wake up the next morning
and she knows it's the day that like D
axis axes coming right so I wake up the
next morning and I send him a text and I
was like
hey he sent you attacks I text him first
oh I didn't tell you this no oh this is
a great boner killer attacks to get from
a girl you [ __ ] the night before hey bro
cinema text that said hey I gotta be
honest with you I feel a little guilty
about what happened last night and I
don't remember what else I was like I'm
also pretty hung over if we hang again
we should probably stay sober I hope
everything goes well my Texas pretty
much like we shouldn't have [ __ ] is
basically the text and he wrote back I'm
hungover - definitely shouldn't booze
for a while definitely do not regret
anything about last night though and I
was like huh okay know what to say and
then and then whatever he wrote me some
other small talk [ __ ] and then he around
like noon he was like kill it tonight
you know have a great show I didn't like
kill her tonight cuz here's the thing we
were friends and truth is if they got
back together and he's happy I'm happy
for him like I want him to be happy I
really do and you know I knew I'm a
grown-up
I knew hooking up with them wasn't a
good idea so like I mean it's not like
he did anything the any guy wouldn't do
and he was a hundred percent honest he
told me she was coming before it
happened but in case she posts it on
Facebook Oh in case you hear about it
some other way I was just thinking
that's he didn't say that that's just
the only way that I would know cuz I her
and I her face will crash there's no
other way I'm funny
yeah Instagram me picking up my [ __ ] at
my accident so the point is yesterday
she comes I never hear from him
yesterday so I'm texting Chen last night
and I'm like she's starting to lose her
cool like around like 9 p.m. no I was
like midnight wasn't it
no it wasn't well I was midnight on the
East Coast I was like do you think I
just midnight somewhere do you think I
should just text him and see if he's
doing ok and Jen is like this is classic
jad and this is why
Jen Jen goes I think you should text him
and go hey babe I'm back from San Diego
why don't I come over and kiss you good
night yeah I was saying basically saying
make up an excuse to go over there and
see if she's still there I'm like that's
crazy I'm not doing that we've hooked up
once we're not together he owes me
nothing really he was honest and of
course like crazy you have to think
crazy okay I know but the thing is like
don't you think in this instance the
best move is to be chill how is being
chill
I have no chill but I'm trying to have
chill so so I did text him but you gave
me the best she said just text him and
go like hey thinking of you so I did
that yeah just to see if he respond yeah
I did that at midnight and he never
answered so I knew I was like oh well
she's definitely still there and then
and then he texts me this morning like
hey yeah you know we're still we're
still talking it out and keep you posted
whatever we're still fighting yeah and
that's it and that's what happened and
so basically I was super bummed not so
much bummed about this guy but bummed
because I [ __ ] up my 30-day challenge
and I was making progress and I was
really proud and I slid back and then in
a moment of weakness because I slid back
and the problem is every time I [ __ ]
another guy it makes me miss the
[ __ ] guy a little bit because
[ __ ] is the best sex I've ever had
in my life
so I was like you know what I'm
depressed I'm gonna text [ __ ] and
just try to try to bang him
I just want to because that's how I
cheer myself up so Erin you're gonna
love this I go on Verizon to unblock
[ __ ] number because I had actually
gone through the Verizon website and
blocked it as like a spam number or
whatever so that it would so that I
couldn't even undo it on my phone
because I'm crazy she has to think about
it like she is to think about the
decision to go on Verizon and to unblock
this number yeah so I go on Verizon to
unblock the number I even something you
can do drunken
like you have to be home in front of a
computer and here's the best part
I go to unblock his number and I realize
that his number hasn't even been blocked
for days so then I'm even more depressed
cuz I was winning like I thought this
[ __ ] was probably sitting at his
house like [ __ ] I miss her I can't
believe she bought my number
no he hasn't even text me I had it
blocked for like a day or two and and
then he probably was texting me things
that we were really like fighting but
then I remember now that I unblocked it
one night and then I was so angry when I
realized this yesterday she went to go
block his number
I want to go block his number again and
I got a message from Verizon saying
crazy [ __ ] go to therapy you block this
number at too many times yeah I got a
message from Verizon saying this number
cannot be blocked again on you so many
times that Verizon thinks I'm insane I
think gave me the number for a therapist
so basically what I'm saying is now
[ __ ] number isn't blocked but I
didn't text him so at least that's
progress I'm making a little progress
but the point is the 30-day challenge
did not go great for me but I'd like to
give props to carry and Arielle and
Chris because they're all still doing it
they're all still doing great and
Brendan what do you think about about
this do you think there's anything for
me to to do to better myself or in
situations like rubbing his eyes like in
a way we're just like are we really
doing this first of all every story
started with and then I had a few drinks
so I mean maybe it's a thing where the
next time you do a 30 day challenge you
also swear off alcohol that's right they
don't probably be way easier you know
that's a good idea cuz I did quit
drinking for a little while yeah a
little while ago and it went really well
yeah I didn't do anything too stupid no
yeah it's good
that's all that you ever think that it's
just like your what you have just a very
and I mean this with all the love in the
world like an addictive impulsive
impulsive personality yeah you know what
I mean
and you it is about power for you and so
like when you realize that the guy's
number wasn't blocked like you panicked
immediately yeah you did I couldn't
believe it I was like goes from zero to
lets drive to his house in under 60
seconds yeah but I don't drive to his
house ever but you would take me to his
house I would take you to his house yeah
another person wanting to go to this
guy's house and camouflage since like my
wine my boyfriend has a Police
Interceptor vehicle it's all black
everything it is yeah and it's really
fast too
so we did you get away no no he just
wanted an old like an older like cop car
chad has been convinced that this guy's
lying to me since like I think he's got
like a baby mama or like multiple
girlfriend situation definitely has he
found drugs like there's something going
on oh he did finally say to me the other
day when we had our big fight when I
blocked his number look for the last
time he what didn't blighters well I did
for like two days I think I'm not sure
but anyway he did say um look I don't
have a girlfriend but you know i dating
lots of people that's a quote
and I was like Lots I didn't know I
thought Lots is a lot I thought maybe
one or two you know others I didn't know
lie just that situation so funny to me
because I'm like what part of living in
Reseda with two other roommates that are
also grown men with like 17 pit bulls in
a Hacienda with a car that's worth
$25,000 that we've decided to put
$20,000 worth of improvements into and
we wear leather vest what part of this
guy says I'm a stable relationship
person and material nothing but nothing
nothing I know how do you explain that
when you take him home for Christmas I
would never take him home
why are you pursuing it then you know
why because because he because I'm
addicted to that I'm addicted to the to
the sex I'm addicted to the sex I really
am I'm trying I'm trying I haven't had
sex with him in weeks I think we should
go to an a a meeting for sex yeah okay
it's just for it's just for addiction
it's not really for loving sex addicts
anonymous I thought about it I'm
thinking about well we have to wrap up
this episode this was this was just an
update no I we can't let you get out
that easy though so since the 30-day
challenge obviously failed like what
happens to you now like is there any
punishment for not like there should be
punishment for not doing the 30 major
yeah there probably should be a
punishment I didn't think of that
and obviously public humiliation does
not bother you because you're doing this
show or too regular well I told you that
I here's what I think the new plan
should be that for the next 30 days I
won't have sex for real and I will only
date guys that you set me up with okay
starting this weekend I need one okay so
this week Saturday one Sunday really you
can compare yeah yes okay perfect
- Mike I think that the other thing
should be you should get more stable guy
friends in your life that tell you how
crazy you are they do they do well I
have anyone as stable as Brunton exactly
you should get Britain's number and text
to me like is this crazy and he'll just
reply yes auto-reply don't do it Kate I
mean what's your phone down right now
I'm texting Jamar neighbours who is
coming on the next episode of date fails
he's waiting outside can you ask him
when you have him on why he thought it
was acceptable to show a girl oh you're
a saying yes you're saying all right
well Jenn this weekend two dates will do
this no sex and no drinking I won't
drink your now frightens your sponsor
and now front in your restaurants you're
welcome
I feel bad we doesn't pass
but you get to deal with crazy texts at
3:00 a.m. it's really rewarding this has
gone really well today I think I feel
really great about this by the way I'm
seeing a therapist now I made my first
appointment with the with the laughing
therapist I'm gonna see the therapist
I'm gonna figure this [ __ ] out figure it
out and if any of you are struggling
like I am thank you I appreciate it and
I love you guys follow Brunton britain
where can they follow you at PB combs at
the Comedy Store at all things comedy he
does car yeah follow at Jennifer serger
everywhere and and I love you guys
follow me at Kate Q funny this has been
date fails see you next time bye